so a bitcoin price has gone through
quite a roller coaster
what do you think is the high point it's
gonna hit
i don't go up forever right i mean i i
think the bitcoin is is going to it's
going to climb in a serpentine fashion
it's going to advance and come back and
it's going to keep
uh it's going to keep climbing
i think that the volatility attracts all
the capital into the marketplace
and so the volatility makes it the most
interesting thing in the financial
universe it also generates massive yield
and massive returns for traders
and that attracts capital like we're
talking about the difference between
five percent return and 500 percent
return
so
the fast money is attracted by the
volatility
the volatility's been decreasing year by
year by year i think that
that it's stabilizing
i don't think we'll see as much
volatility in the future as we have in
the past
i think that um
[Music]
if we look at bitcoin and model it as
digital gold you know the market cap
goes to between 10 and 20 trillion
but
gold is remember gold is is defective
property gold is dead money
you have a billion dollars of gold this
in a vault for a decade it's very hard
to mortgage the gold it's also very hard
to rent the gold you can't loan the gold
no one's going to create a business with
your gold
so gold it doesn't generate much of a
yield so for that reason most people
wouldn't store a billion dollars for a
decade in gold they would buy a billion
dollars of commercial real estate
property
and the reason why is because i can rent
it and generate a yield on it that's in
excess of the maintenance cost so if you
consider digital property
that's a hundred
to two hundred trillion dollar
uh addressable market so i would think
it you know it goes from ten trillion to
a hundred trillion as people start to
think of it as digital property what
does that mean in terms of price
uh per per coin at 500 000
right that's a 10 trillion dollar asset
at 5 million that's a 100 trillion
dollar asset so i think it crosses a
million it can go even higher
yeah i think it keeps going up forever i
mean there's a reason we can go to 10
million a coin
right because
digital property isn't the highest form
right gold was that low frequency money
property is a mid-frequency money but
when i start to
when i start to um program it
faster it starts to look like digital
energy
and and
then it doesn't just replace property
then you're starting to replace bonds
it's 100 trillion in bonds there's
50 to 100 trillion in other currency
derivatives
and then and then and these are all
conventional use cases right i think
that there's
350 trillion to 500 trillion dollars
worth of
currency currency derivatives in the
world
and that and when i say that i mean
things that are valued based upon fiat
cash flows any commercial real estate
any bond any sovereign debt any any
currency itself any derivatives to those
things they're all
derivatives and they're all defective
and they're all defective because of
this persistent 7 to 14 percent
lapse inflate which we call inflation or
monetary expansion
you